you're gonna mandate that people wear
masks in the home well good news
democrats are here for you
gavin newsom now says that you should
wear a mask at home
according to newsweek ahead of
thanksgiving california governor gavin
newsom and the california department of
public health
released new safety guidelines for all
private gatherings amid the ongoing
coven 19 pandemic
the new rules come with strict
restrictions that aim to help reduce the
risk of spreading infection
gatherings are defined in social
situations that bring together people
from different households
at the same time in a single space or
place when people from different
households mix
this increases the risk of transmission
of kovid 19.
all gatherings must include no more than
three households including hosts
and guests and must be held outdoors
lasting for two hours or less i
have a question why for two hours or
less we've been told you can transmit
this thing in 15 minutes
so why not 15 minutes or less seriously
what is the scientific
evidence that two hours or less is going
to be the great barrier here
and also i understand you want it
outdoors because it has better
ventilation
but they are now suggesting that if it's
like me
and my parents i guess that that is two
households in the state of california so
it's me my parents and my sister
then that is three households in the
state of california i'm sure this is
going to be st
and and what what's going to happen the
cops can come knock on your door and
arrest you
or find you if you get together with
family members on thanksgiving that's
yeah i'm sure this is gonna be wildly
effective i'm sure you know what
you're right we need to elect joe
biden's that we can have the federal
officers come to your house if you are
in a house with you
and your parents and your sister's
family we need the feds
at your door if this sounds like a
dystopian sci-fi novel it's because
we've basically reached that point
according to what is now being requested
all in order to prevent the transmission
of a disease
that is not extraordinarily deadly for
people under the age of 70 but is
extraordinarily deadly for people who
are above the age of 70.
okay which means that last chance we are
all rational and sentient human beings
by the way when i say extraordinary
deadly i'm comparing it to like
extraordinarily deadly diseases like
ebola or the bubonic plague
because the flu is not extraordinarily
deadly i'm not comparing it to the flu
before you know social media say i'm com
i'm not comparing it to the flu i've
been very precise in my language here
this is about three times as deadly as
the flu for people who are
between the ages of approximately 40 and
70. it's about twice as deadly as the
flu
for people between the ages of 20 and 40
and the reality is not that many people
die of the flu every year on a
population adjusted basis
so is it deadly yes is it highly highly
highly deadly in the mold of like
mirrors no it is not okay but we are now
going to have what federal officers
banging on your door if you get together
with some people over thanksgiving
and california is going to do this the
new rules state those at a gathering may
remove their face coverings briefly to
eat or drink
as long as they stay six feet away from
everyone outside their own household and
put their face covering back on as soon
as they are done with the activity
the latest guidelines at face coverings
can also be removed to meet urgent
medical needs
the existing face coverings also set out
by the cd ph also apply they say
everyone must wear face coverings in
high risk situations
including in outdoor public spaces when
maintaining a six feet distance outside
from those outside your household
is not feasible also no singing no
chanting no shouting
and you should participate in quiet
activity
musicians are allowed at gatherings but
they must be from one of the three
households also no playing of wind
instruments
so uh yeah this is all going to go great
i'm sure everybody is going to abide by
this in california
i'm sure that every single person is
going to abide by this in california by
the way the state with the most
confirmed
coveted cases in the united states
california with 855 000 confirm covet
cases despite massive
lockdown restrictions and all of this
coveted talk is predicated on the notion
that if you just flip a switch it goes
away and that switches trump that is a
pagan
silly notion it is not true facts don't
care about your feelings and it's a fact
that the ben shapiro show is the largest
conservative podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content